avant la naissance de bruce lee avant la
naissance de hitman
la plus grande héroïne du monde du kung
fu était une jeune femme
lady kung fu
entraînez suivant l'antique voie du
guerrier initiés aux techniques
chinoises de combat les plus mortelles
aucun coup de pieds n'était plus rapide
aucun coup de poing n'allait plus vite
et aucun homme ne pouvait rivaliser avec
les guides kung fu
maintenant elle doit réunir son courage
et ses forces pour faire face à son plus
grand défi et se battre pour protéger sa
famille et son pays dans un combat final
pirat jusqu'à la mort
avec l'actrice multi-récompensé widing
end
le couple terrible urinoirs et wayne
shaw et coligny chou de matrix reloaded
et du royaume interdit et pour la
première fois à l'écran
by jing
dans le rôle de lady kung fu une
production seasonal film